Speaker 1: Let's start today with some very
interesting economic news, despite sort of
being held up by Republicans as the example of
everything that is bad and that should not be
done, and that is a disaster of the progressive
left. California's economy is leading the nation
in growth and in fact, is growing almost as
quickly as the major developing nation of China,
if you can believe it. And you know, this
gloom and doom about lockdown's and liberal
policies and all of this stuff, it really seems
not to have held back the state of California,
which is number one in terms of GDP growth in
the United States, increasing household income,
investing in innovation, a whole bunch of other
metrics. It's California that's number one. And
once again, and this has been I mean, go back
all the way to the beginning of Reaganomics and
supply side and trickle down economic realities
seem to increasingly be the exact opposite of
what right wingers want you to believe in terms of
GDP growth. California has grown 22 percent since
2015. These are incredible numbers. California has
grown on a percentage basis, more than Germany,
more than Japan, more than the United States
overall, and almost as much as China. China,
a developing nation that is experiencing a
rapid economic growth, expanding middle class,
etc.. China has grown twenty nine percent since
2015. California has grown almost to that amount.
And in the midst of this, they're trying to
recall Democratic Governor Gavin Newsom. And
yet the state is growing almost as quickly as
China. California added one point three million
people to its non-farm payrolls since
last April. Household income increased
one hundred and sixty four billion dollars,
almost as much as Texas, Florida and Pennsylvania
combined. California's budget surplus. Yeah,
it's a surplus. You wouldn't know this from
listening to Fox News about California. The
California surplus has grown to a record.
Seventy five billion dollars revenue per employee
has grown in California much more quickly than in
the rest of the United States. So there are some
really important takeaways here as we think about
what this sensible economic policy look like
at the state level. First of all, the constant,
endless ranting from Republicans about how
terrible everything is in California economically,
socially, culturally and otherwise. It's just
not true. Is California expensive? Absolutely.
California is expensive in the net. Our taxes
higher in California for someone of average income
than in many other states. That really depends.
There's this study that looked at Texas versus
California for someone making I think it was
like between 60 and 80 thousand dollars a year.
And if you really account for all of the expenses
that are levied by the state in California versus
Texas. And so you look at local and property sales
taxes, fees on cars and other different things,
it ends up being slightly cheaper to live in
California than Texas for the average person,
even accounting for the California state income
tax. But the more important takeaway is, you know,
more recently, the covid lockdown's, as they were
called, which not that many people in California
were even really abiding by the right, was saying
covid lockdown's are destroying California.
They didn't destroy the state. California is doing
really well. California is in the top states in
terms of portion of its population vaccinated,
which is sort of a logistical and infrastructure
signal about California. So the bottom line is
California is expensive, but it's expensive for
a reason. And you would think that Republicans
would understand this. The people who talk about
the free market, the reason that California is
expensive is there's really high demand and a lot
of people want to live there. Why do things cost
a lot? Sometimes things cost a lot because lots of
people want to buy them. That's called the market.
Now, that being said, California, like every
state, still has many problems that many metro
areas have because it's in demand. It prices out
lots of people, including people who want to live
there but can't afford to. That's a real issue.
We can recognize. It's expensive because people
want to live there and that is a market based
thing. But at the same time, a lot of people
are getting priced out. That's a real issue.
We still have huge inequality in both wealth
and income. California is no exception to that.
But the lies that you're being fed by people like
Tucker Carlson and Laura Ingraham and various
of the Trumps and others about the dystopian
California, it's not true. The undeniable reality
is that California is the envy of the world in
terms of an economy. If California were a country,
it would be a significant country. Globally, and
it's just one of 50 states in the United States
in terms of average standard of living, in
terms of innovation, in terms of technology,
some of the best places in the world to live are
in California. There aren't in West Virginia.
Right. I'm not attacking West Virginia
or the people of West Virginia. But what
I'm saying is there's a massive infrastructure
difference between California and West Virginia.
There is a massive education quality difference.
There's a massive health care quality difference.
Wages are significantly higher. And yeah. So all
of that together makes California expensive and
it makes West Virginia really cheap. It has to
do with politics. It has to do with demand. And
it's actually stunning that Republicans get away
with trashing California when it's an obviously
incredibly dynamic economy that in many ways
is the envy of the world. California would
be a globally successful country, and it's just
one of 50 states. And in the midst of this, are
they going to recall the governor, Gavin Newsom? I
don't know. We will see and we're going to follow
it. But the doom and gloom about California, it
is just not backed up by the numbers. And they
don't you know, it's it's obviously a transparent
political attack. There's no question about that.
But the degree to which it's transparently bogus
is only becoming more clear now as we start to
get this data as we emerge from the pandemic.
And they're not going to change their tune. But
hopefully you now will know that the bogus attacks
on California are just that. They're simply bogus